et
l'on pense maintenant à notre cas du
samedi soir
fabien changea bonsoir
les stars de la nouvelle saison de koh
lanta aux îles fidji mais vous venez
fabian de beaucoup plus loin dès votre
naissance devait été rejetée par votre
mère biologique qui vous a confiée à sa
mère mais cette drôle de grand mère ne
veut pas s'occuper de vous et vous
laissent à l'abandon dans un poulailler
vous êtes nourrit en cachette par un
voisin jusqu'à l'âge de 3 ans et vous
serez découvert lors d'un incendie est
adopté et après bien des péripéties
vous vous retrouvez sur tf1 dans koh
lanta incroyable histoire
[Musique]
alors fabian rocha rocha vous aider le
19 août
1969 à castillo son uruguay votre mère
biologique à ce moment-là a déjà
accouché cette fois elle n'a pas les
moyens de s'occuper de vous elle décide
de vous confier à sa mère dont votre
grand mère mais cette dernière ne veut
pas d'un enfant à charge elle vous
installe au fond de son jardin dans un
poulailler c'était ça ou vous tuer en
fait je pense que c'est ça c'est
peut-être la peur de me tuer ouais alors
compte tenu de l'implantation du village
en fête il y avait des murs qui séparent
et les maisons des terres qui séparait
les clapiers des poulaillers finalement
été très facile de vous laisser mourir à
l'abri des regards d'autant plus que
c'était la dictature militaire à
l'époque en uruguay et que les gens
évitent est de s'intéresser aux
histoires de leurs voisins
c'est ça c'est entièrement ça c'est la
peur mais le gémissement dans le
poulailler sans doute dû à la fin et au
froid met la puce à l'oreille d'un
voisin qui décide de s'occuper de vous
sans rien dire à personne il vous couvre
il vous nourrit il vous aime en fait il
fait le maximum pour vous maintenir en
vie ce type là
cette situation va quand même duré deux
ans
vous êtes un petit enfant sauvage à
l'époque comme on a eu en europe des
exemples l'enfant loup qui été élevé
comme ça vous êtes livré à vous-même
quoi tout ça il faut imaginer qu'un
enfant
s'il n'est pas motivé il se lève pas
ouais
by parle pas il parle pas on se crée
dans le regard de l'autre ouais quand ya
pas de regard en face on se crée pas y'a
rien c'est ça alors vous avez trois ans
quand un incendie se déclare dans le
poulailler et les pompiers découvrent à
ce moment là un gosse qui ne parlent pas
et qui est incapable de marcher ils
savent pas quoi faire de vous ils me
prennent bien sûr voilà bonsoir une vie
quand même les pompiers et
je vais au poste de police et puis là on
sait pas comment faire ils parlent pas
et sert à rien donc
on décide de me raser et là il ya un
notable du village qui décide de vous
adoptez
et de vous confier à sa fille s'appelle
hausse marino
un mec assez de pognon quand même un
effet travaillé comme 300 personnes dans
ces riches ils payent des bakchichs
nécessaires à l'adoption parce que ce
n'était pas évident non plus d'adopter
quelqu'un et zafira qu'elle devient
votre mère adoptive ça énorme coup de
bol énorme coup de bol ici la voix oui
thierry dès que vous aurez fini de
raconter ce conte de fées est-ce que
vous pourrez raconter la véritable vie
de fabian c'est la véritable vie tu vas
bien cesag et d'incroyables ensuite asma
raynaud vous fait passer la douane pour
aller à sao paulo au brésil c'était pas
évident puisque passer la douane avec un
môme qui sait pas parler qui sait pas
marcher qu'à pas de papiers et qui rique
locaux rico
c'est moche seulement qu'il savait
c'était
compliqué
3 elle est légale mais je fais mieux le
coq que la poule paraît
il c'est au brésil que vous commencez à
apprendre à marcher et à parler alors au
brésil j'ai vers la fin des trois ans et
demi aurait ensuite donc raquel votre
mère adoptive qui est infirmière
cherchent à quitter le continent
sud-américain pour s'exiler en australie
ou en suisse elle veut refaire sa vie
elle veut vous faire une belle vie c'est
vrai que là bas c'est à l'époque c'était
pas très facile donc elle cherche et
finalement je vais six ans lorsque en
1975 votre mère adoptive raquel été
autorisés à émigrer en suisse et là vous
vous retrouvez avec elle à la chaux de
fonds comme le faire et là vous suivez
un traitement et du fluor et du calcium
pour renforcer votre corps parce
qu'effectivement le fait d'avoir été
laissés à l'abandon dans ce poulailler
dans votre prime enfance nous a pas
aidés vous porter des prothèses pour
votre dos pour avoir une posture normale
vous apprenez les langues vous apprenez
les bonnes manières si vous ne savez
rien n'est vraiment lancée là on est
bien d'accord et en deux ans vous
apprenez fabian le français et
l'espagnol
en trois ans le français l'espagnol
l'italien le portugais mais voilà litres
à damas arrêtant il a rattrapé le temps
perdu qu'on aime faisons cocorico
aura neuf ans vous savez écrire vous
rentrez dans une école normale mais vous
êtes ostracisé par vos camarades à cause
de vos béquilles on vous appelle
quasimodo c'est très dur ça c'est dur
mais je subis pas fait ce genre de
choses jusqu'au jour effectivement on
m'a poussé dans le dos la même attention
à la quasimodo 1 on le pousse il tombe
il se relève il fracasse un arrêt il
faudra attendre l'âge de 12 ans pour que
vous puissiez vous passez de vaud
prothèses et c'est là que raquel dans
votre mère adoptive
décide de déménager à morges pour vous
offrir une nouvelle vie formidable bras
qu'elle décide de vous emmener ailleurs
pour vous soyez un homme nouveau là bas
j'aurais voulu qu'elle soit là ce soir
ouais je comprends elle est plus là mais
j'aurais voulu que l'on aimait enfant
surtout way et poussins ouais c'est mais
pousse à exactement hélas ce qui est
incroyable c'est que quand vous arrivez
à morges on découvre que vous êtes un
surdoué dire que vous avez un quotient
intellectuel qui dépasse 140 et en fait
c'est une sorte de on peut dire
d'autistes asperger c'est à dire que
vous avez une capacité intellectuelle
supérieure à la moyenne on s'en rend
compte à ce moment là oui alors je sais
pas si c'est un bien ou un mal
alors c'est peut-être un bien
effectivement parce que je me suis
reconstruit rapidement parce que je suis
vraiment comme une éponge tout d'un coup
j'ai fait de la physio gilet fluo je
viens musclée je suis intelligente j'ai
la plaque de choc et tout ce qui va avec
ça les poules n'ont pas eh ben tout à
coup je suis confronté à la vie avec
l'ina qui me tombe dessus disons il est
incroyable ce mec
c'est super pour moi j'ai pas prêt à ça
c'est comme si on gagne les milliards
tout en maintenant la seconde et puis on
n'est pas prêt et je n'étais pas prêt à
ça alors malgré tous ces talents vous
arrêtez vos études vous mettez au boulot
vous serez maître nageur couvreur
chauffagistes électriciens
mais chaque métier vous l'apprenez très
très vite et à chaque fois que vous
bossez vous devenez chef d'equipe à
bâcher la perle d'or pour les
entreprises ouais j'apprends tout très
rapidement mais payés que grosses
pierres vous avez 25 ans quand vous
décidez de faire une thérapie je vous
êtes jaloux en fait vous êtes jaloux lui
et sa très mal sans doute c'est dû à
votre manque d'amour dans votre enfance
en la thérapie va durer trois ans et là
votre mère adoptive on craque elle part
en uruguay pour s'occuper de ses
grands-parents et en
1999 et donc trente ans vous décidé de
la rejoindre en uruguay
raquel souffrent du diabète elle
développe une gangrène aux jambes il
faut l'amputer et vous êtes là pour la
soutenir je pense que c'est le passage
de ma vie le plus difficile en fait et
c'est de voir cette personne vraiment
c'est quelqu'un qui qui adore tout est
là tout d'un coup
petit à petit elle dépérit avaient péri
elle dépérit jusqu'au jour où elle veut
plus ouais mais elle a pas voulu partir
quand j'étais là un qu'elle vous apprend
que l'une de vos soeurs biologique
sandra travaille pas loin elle et lui
dit elle caissière dans un supermarché
vous y allez et là vous voyez votre
soeur s'est vous en femme quoi ah ouais
on a le
la même les moustaches donc la même tête
là vous
bah oui c'est ma soeur c'est incroyable
on n'a rien pu se dire tout de suite on
était à cette distance là et
jusqu'à 4 il ya tout cas démarrer mais
hélas sandra vous met en relation avec
laeticia une autre de vos soeurs qui est
marié avec le fils du mec qui vous
nourrissent et en cachette non
on va dire que l'uruguay est petit
et puis je dois juste incroyable c'est
lors de ce voyage vous refusé de
rencontrer votre mère biologique pour
vous c'est pas votre mère en fait je la
connais pas cette dame gré vous l'avez
jamais vu en fait alors je n'ai vu par
les réseaux sociaux maintenant j'ai mes
frères qui ne partagent way sa photo et
tout ça je leur ai dit voilà ça
m'intéresse pas c'est une dame que je te
croiser dans la rue
ça vous intéresse pas non vraiment pas
non non en 2000 vous êtes en europe
quand vous apprenez que raquel et
mourront vous décidez d'y aller
malheureusement vous ne partirai jamais
parce qu'elle meure avant vieillit le
temps de monter dans l'avion je devais
partir le matin est décédée pendant la
nuit ouais vous n'avez jamais revu je
n'ai jamais revu
et puis je me suis dit à quoi bon
descendre là ce moment là mais ici la
voix thierry lorsque vous aurez terminé
le ce mélodrame est-ce que vous pourrez
raconter la vraie vie de fabien
1 35 ans vous rencontrez fanni mais elle
a rencontré ou fanny au travail ah ouais
là je fais concierge homme à tout faire
dans un stade aux expositions où je
faisais les nettoyages aussi le soir et
tout et puis elle et les secrétaires à
l'accueil voilà j'ai été le coup de
foudre tout ça ouais tout de suite tout
de suite quand vous l'avez vu ses love
at first sight ouais ouais alors vous
les poudres et trois ans plus tard fanni
c'est aussi l'époque où fait tatouer le
visage c'est quand même une décision
importante pourquoi c'était quoi l'idée
pour moi fanny
c'est ma troisième vie à ma troisième et
puis ma super vie en fait ouais pour moi
c'était ce passage la sas et représente
absolument aucune tribu aucune au cargö
on m'a posé des questions grâce à un
brouillon mais qui valeureux ouais
c'était un passage pour moi et c'est un
passage obligé est ce que c'est pas une
façon de lire finalement je suis pas
comme vous peut-être j'ai vécu autre
chose que vous donnez moi je pense que
c'est aussi une porte mais cette porte
justement elle permet de
de s'ouvrir à moi ensuite toujours la
recherche d'une vie stable et équilibrée
avec fanny vous faites deux enfants qui
au et elvis et vous faites naturalisé
suisse donc aujourd'hui on a un suisse
en face de nous mesdames messieurs vous
obtenez votre certificat fédéral
d'éducateur donc là maintenant vous êtes
un citoyen suisse marié père de famille
modèle vous avez obtenu votre
naturalisation le 1er août jour de la
fête nationale suisse est un symbole sa
symbole premier route tu es content
gamelle 12 je suis content dit dans les
banques suisses maman
et puis à koh lanta alors peu de femmes
vous inscrire en 2012 est pas retenue
mais ça marche en 2016 ou deuxième essai
vais gagner là bas
on passe pas il est le truc en mêlée
bien aidés bien moi j'ai des infos il
est bien là mais il est bientôt tu es un
fan de koh lanta web c'est tout public
tu regarde ça avec les gosses et c'est
plaisant quoi est-ce que fabian richard
chat va gagner koh lanta alors si vous
reviendrez ici vous célébrera cette
jeune célébration pour moi ce soir alors
vous voulez monter une société de team
building
ya pour en durcir les gens en fait je
veux faire des camps pour monsieur et
madame tout le monde ouais mais grand
poulailler pour voilà exactement grand
poulailler on se couvre tous après dès
que ça fais gaffe parce que des camps
pour monsieur madame tout le monde ça
déjà existé ça passe a bien marché mais
ça a laissé un arrière-goût
alors vous avez une devise que j'aime
bien il n'y a pas de problème il n'y a
que des solutions ouais c'est ce qui
m'anime depuis toujours et corrections
de ne rien rater de inhabituel abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu